SIR ANTHONY SELDON: And
thanks everybody for coming.
And who here feels happy?
Who here would
like to be happier?
Who thanks deep down
that other people are
responsible for your happiness?
Who blames other people for you
for the unhappiness that you
feel?
Who blames others, in
part, for the unhappiness
that you feel in your life?
And lastly, who believes
that we have it in our power
to be unbelievably happy?
So the question then is-- let me
just begin just by asking you,
what is it that is
stopping you being happier,
given that you all think
that you could be happier?
What is it that's blocking you?
And we're going to be
doing some exercises
and I do want to get
you on your backs.
And as I'm just
looking at you there,
I'm trying to think how
I'm going to do that
but we'll do it.
I want you to-- just answer
that question actually
to begin with.
What is it-- just some ideas.
What is it that's blocking
you being happier?
Ego.
Time.
What is this thing called ego?
I mean all my life people
have talked about ego
and no one's ever really
satisfactorily defined it.
What is ego?
AUDIENCE: Your mind-- the
voice in your mind [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON:
Your voice in your mind,
which is self-referencing.
Time.
Why is time a problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON:
There's never enough time.
But what does that mean,
there's never enough time.
What you're actually
saying is, be honest,
I don't choose to-- who's
in charge your time?
So rephrase that question in a
way that takes responsibility
for the answer.
I am not giving the
time that I would
like to give it to thinking
about my own happiness.
Is happiness selfish?
Hands up.
Can I just see, who thinks
that happiness, being happy
is fundamentally selfish?
Who thinks it's
fundamentally the best
thing for you and for everyone
who loves you to be happy?
You know, just one of many
misconceptions about happiness
is that we think it's selfish.
All of you think now of
somebody, a brother, a sister,
parent, friend, who is very
unhappy, seriously unhappy.
And how does that make you
feel when you think about them?
What?
How does it make you feel?
Unhappy.
Drags you down.
Unhappiness drags us down.
And now let's think of
somebody that's really happy,
a brother or sister, get real.
Parents, who, somebody's
really happy around you.
Just think about that person
and think what they do to you.
I think what you could
now do to everyone round
you, if, fundamentally--
and the proposition
is that we all lead lives
which could become much more
fulfilling and much happier and
much more meaningful and much
more considered.
And we're looking at
why that doesn't happen.
And we talked about this thing,
this self-referencing mind.
And we talked about
us choosing not
to make time available
for us, while blaming
everybody else and
the cat and the dog
for not giving us enough time.
What else?
What else stops us
from being happier?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: Fear?
Fear of what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: Fear
of not getting it right.
Is fear a powerful
emotion in you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: Fear is a
powerful emotion in all of us.
Sometimes we're afraid to make
the choices that we could make
that would make us happier.
Just a couple more things.
What's stopping
us being happier?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: Fear
that the person next door,
working in that next door
screen or next door office here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: So how
can one deal with that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: OK.
Or you could be more accepting.
Just one more thing
because you are
going to go out of here
at 5:30 and some of you
will be unchanged and others
of you will be changed.
Others of you I will leave here
with a fundamentally enhanced
drive about going and
making yourself happier.
So let's just think, right.
I think we've done enough
thinking about that.
I want us just to
be very still now.
And OK, so I want us
to close our eyes.
Everybody close their eyes.
A lot of clicking, listens to
the clicking and the ringing
and air con and the
noise round about you.
I want you to sit
up, sit upright.
And just find that nice
point of-- that nice point
of balance for your back.
You know, it's wonderful
to find the position
for standing and sitting.
This is something that
if you don't do it,
you can really take away
with renewed energy,
is to find a position we could
all adopt that will not give us
back pain, not make us need
to go to how's have massages
for back pain.
The massages are very nice,
but where we feel just
properly balance.
Try and see if you could
find that point in the back.
I want you to earth your
feet, really earth your feet.
And if you're-- my eyes
are closed by the way.
So can't see what you're doing.
But if you a standing up,
you might want to sit down.
And I want you just
to breathe deeply.
The mind plays
many tricks on us.
One is it denies
to us that there
are levels of stillness
that we can all
it experience, which
are profoundly restful.
I'm asking you, if you
don't know this already,
and it's not a
question of belief,
it's a question of
knowledge, that if you
don't know levels of
inner silence and rest
and stillness, which are
beyond words, to accept
there is that state.
And what stopping us getting
there is all the things
we talked about,
the restless mind,
the clicking of the
door, the noises outside.
So I'm asking us,
or I'm inviting you,
I'm inviting you to let
go of the turning mind
and to experience yourself,
not believe, not think about,
thinking is not
going to help here,
it's about letting
go of thinking.
Experience a level of
stillness beyond anything
you've experienced
today, beyond anything
you've experienced this week.
And to understand that, in
making ourselves happier
and thinking more about
our own well-being.
This is profoundly helpful
for everyone round us.
We're better for colleagues
if we are happier and look
after our well-being.
We're better for ourselves.
We're better for
everyone who loves us,
everyone who works with us.
So there's nothing
selfish about this.
There's nothing selfish about
taking time out of your life
and to care for your own mental
health, psychological health,
physical health,
spiritual health,
and embrace a level of stillness
which will give you happiness,
which is beyond nourishment,
beyond any pleasure
that cocaine and
sex and any Lord
or whatever it
wants to indulge in.
It is beyond happiness
is the title of the book.
It's beyond pleasure,
it's beyond happiness.
It's a level of complete,
utter acceptance of oneself
and of other people, not
as a belief, but as a fact,
an experience that we
can have all our lives.
We can carry around
all our lives.
And so breathing
and loving your body
and getting to know your body
is really fundamental in this.
So just run a scan over
your body and over your mind
at the moment, with the eyes
closed and in a relaxed, really
relaxed position.
And the feet grounded, just
feel the pressures of the day
just coming out
through the feet.
Imagine that you're walking
around at home, barefoot.
Think how wonderful that can be
walking barefoot, maybe walking
on a beach barefoot on a lawn.
And just feel that sense
of contact earthiness
between the sole of the
foot and the ground.
Let all the tension
just come out
through those many, many nerves
in the bottom of the feet.
Just let it drain out
and just sense yourself,
just feel how your feet and your
lower legs are, just notice.
If it's holding tension
there, just let it go.
If you are, just come up through
the knees and the thighs.
Come up through your whole
sitting area, your abdomen,
coming up to the lower trunk.
Just see what's there.
Are you holding tension?
Are you holding on to things?
Just notice.
This whole journey into
happiness is about noticing.
It's about letting go
and it's about seeing
what's really present and
accepting it and embracing it.
And then letting it go.
And coming up through the core,
the chest, shoulders, hands.
Coming through the-- coming up
through the hands, the palms.
Just hold them out.
Just feel the heat of the sun.
Feel the heat of the sun.
Imagine on your palms, the
warmth radiating through.
Goodness coming into the
body through the hands
and coming up through
the forearms, the elbows,
the upper arms, the shoulders.
Just feel all the tension now
coming out of the shoulders.
Just if you're holding on
to it, you can let it go.
In the same way that
if you're holding
on in your mind to
anxious thoughts
about what am I going
to do tonight, what am I
going to pick up
the dinner, how am I
going to finish this
assignment, what does so and so
think of me, let it all go.
Because it's not here now.
What's here now is us
and the present moment.
And that present moment
is always a present.
it's always a reminder
that we can just
live in the present
moment, or we can live
in our heads, lost in thought.
So we're in the present
moment now together.
And just feel your
sense of everybody.
Just slightly embarrassing
to do this, but just
mentally embrace
everybody in this space.
Just feel as if your arms
are coming around the person
next to you.
And feel them around you.
Feel their support
and acceptance.
And extend beyond them to people
further away and to everybody
in this room.
They are telling you that you
can accept yourself, that it's
fine to be as you are.
And accept that.
Just feel your whole self, your
whole face becoming lighter,
feel a calm, gently
warm breeze coming,
passing through your face, over
your cheeks, over your eyes.
Feel just a warm glow on
your eyes, just letting go.
When you feel the thought,
let it go, let it go.
And just be here
now in this room.
There's no anxiety in this room.
There's no pressure.
There are no enemies.
There's just good people,
good human beings,
who want the best for you.
And breathing is the
core of our being
and we are not taught how
to breathe in this country
or in most countries.
But breathing is wonderful.
So keeping that
still good posture,
just breathing in to
the count of three,
coming in, one, two,
three, and hold that.
And coming out, one, and
two, and three, four, five,
and inhaling, coming
in, deep breath.
One, two, three, and hold it.
And exhaling through
the nostrils.
Feel the air come out through
the nostrils, two, and three,
and four, and five.
Inhaling, feel the air coming
in through the nostrils,
and one, and two, and
three and hold it.
And exhaling, one,
two, three, four, five.
And inhaling, real
depth in here,
coming in, coming in, and
one, and two, and three,
and just feel the
point between the eyes.
Just hold that.
And exhaling, one, two,
just listen to those noises
and accept them, and
three, and four, and five.
The concentration is very
important, by the way.
Try and keep the concentration
on the tip of the nose,
coming in just one last time,
in, one, and two, and three,
and exhaling, one, two,
three, four, and five.
Just notice, breathing under
your own time, notice the mind.
Is the mind any different
at all to how it's been?
Just notice the mind.
Are you feeling any sense
of greater acceptance?
And I just want you to
keep the eyes closed.
And I want you to
recall the time
in your life when you have
felt the stillest, the calmest,
that you've ever
felt. A real time.
And once you've alighted
on that experience,
that occasion, just try and
recall what it was about that
and how that felt. I want
you to move towards it.
I want you to just let
that sense come to you now.
See if you can hear the distant
smell of it, the distant ripple
or echo of it here now.
I want you to see
yourself as you would like
to be in front of yourself.
I want you just to see yourself
as you would dearly love to be.
With the qualities, the
attributes, the person
who would be superbly
happy, the person who
is beyond any worldly
recognition of money or status
or reward.
But maybe those things
are important too.
If they are, include them.
And if they are, just see
them there in front of you.
Visualization is,
as you all know,
incredibly powerful, or can be.
See that person, and
walk towards that person.
And feel what's left
inside, you feel
the-- whatever
inadequacies you might feel
or hurts that you might have.
And just walk up to
that person and embrace
them, this supremely happy
person, this supremely happy
you and just see you
coming together as one.
And we're going to do just one
or two exercises with orange
and one or two other things.
But I want you just
before that, just
to do the cathartic exercise
of imagining that you
have a cushion in front you.
You've got two cushions.
And one of them could be
your boss or your partner
or your father and the
other could be your mother
or your best friend.
And you've got in your
hand a big wooden spoon,
a big, heavy wooden
spoon, old and heavy.
And I want you to,
having imagined
who those cushions
are, I want you
to see yourself, on that first
cushion, really hitting it.
And just see if you can
connect with letting
go, which is the key to
happiness, letting go.
It's not about acquiring.
The happiness is inside us.
We don't have to go
anywhere or do anything.
We just have to let go.
So letting go, really
hit, see yourself
really beating
that cushion hard,
cushion A, whoever
that is to you.
You can work yourself
up in a frenzy.
You can make noises.
Screaming at it.
And then coming
over, you can still
love this person, whoever A is.
Come over to B,
and you could still
love B very much,
whoever B is and take
that wooden, large ladle,
spoon in your hand.
And come up to B and just
hit it and get whatever
you want to out of your system.
Anger that is something
the corrupts us,
and so many people take anger
to their graves with them.
Parents, grandparents, take
anger, take fear, take sadness,
take regret to their graves.
What we're saying here is these
things will be part of you
and they will occlude
your happiness
unless you take responsibility
and start acting to assimilate
them and to let them go.
So you're hitting that cushion
B, whoever that is that.
It's not anybody in the room,
cushion B. And so just let
yourself rip into cushion B.
Just one last one is
to come to-- imagine,
eyes closed, the
most sacred space,
what is your most sacred space?
Just see it.
Is it a building,
a field, a beach,
a presence with someone
else, a room, an object?
Come into that sacred space,
and whatever your fears
and sadnesses are, lay
them in that sacred space,
knowing that the sacred
space will absorb them.
The sacred space will
not be diminished.
The sacred space to grow if
you can do this, and just
lay them there.
And then, take it and
place it and then walk away
or give if these things up.
They're imaginings.
They're not real.
They're imaginings that we carry
with us forever unless we act.
So there we are.
That's some of the journey.
I would like, while we
just take some questions,
can I just maybe put
these between three?
I didn't quite know how
they're going to work out.
Maybe we'll take an
orange between two
and a flower between three.
Can I just ask, while
we're doing that,
did any questions arise
or any observations
from that exercise?
One flower I think between
three or actually maybe,
I think we're going to do this.
We can actually break
them off the main stem.
Can you break them so
everybody has their own flower.
And just while we're doing--
while we're doing that,
can you look at your flower.
OK, just keeping the
concentration everybody.
Does any question emerge
while we were doing that?
Anyone fall asleep?
Falling asleep is fine.
But I would like to see
you at the end the session
for an explanation.
OK.
Have you all got a flower?
I want you to look
at your flower
now in the present moment.
Do you all know what I mean by
the difference between looking
at the flower in
the present moment
and looking at the flower in
the ordinary state of mind.
What is the difference?
It's simple awareness, yeah.
Do it knowingly.
So if you can look
at your flower now
and if you could study it with
total concentration on it.
Look at it with an intensity
and a power of acute observation
that you have never done before.
You have never had
this moment before.
You have never seen
this power before.
This is a unique moment
in human history.
And look at it with
an intense love,
and an intense awareness of
if the colors, the shapes.
And now just touch
it to your cheek.
Just feel, gently, just
sense that sensation.
And now bring it to
your nose, and there's
just ever say slight sense.
And with that, just feel
an acute love for that,
as if it's their most
precious possession.
And now give it to the
person next to you.
Give it with love.
Give it with total love.
OK, have you got an orange
more or less between two.
Who has not got an
orange between two?
Who has got an
orange between one?
OK.
Gently and not in
a way as if you
would be beating the cushions.
Could we get an
orange between three?
Who now doesn't have an
OK.
So can we have-- there's a
sense of orangelessness here.
All right so, can
we just descatter.
Can I ask, who practices
mindfulness here already?
OK.
Mindfulness is about the
descattering of the mind.
It's an approach which is
thousands of years old,
which the Western world
thinks it's now discovering.
It is thousands of years
old and it is simply
about savoring the
present moment.
It's about a
conscious awareness.
Who here's aware of walking
or driving across London
or catching a tube home,
getting home, putting
the key in the lock, and
thinking, how did I do that?
Has anyone ever had
that experience?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: OK.
I mean doing that is
fine, doing that is fine,
but that is not mindfulness.
Mindfulness is about being
aware of what you're doing.
So taking that
orange between two,
could we just open
that orange up.
And could you share
with somebody else
and I want to do it mindfully.
Just do it very consciously.
And then can you pass a
piece of the fruit, a segment
of the fruit, to somebody else.
Don't eat it yet.
OK.
And of course,
everyone's cleaned
that hands so it's to
be absolutely-- Just
smell that orange,
that aroma of orange.
OK.
Could you now pass a piece
of orange to everybody.
So everybody hold-- OK, so
moving the oranges round,
so everybody has a
segment of orange.
Can you just pass them round
once you've got them open.
And could I also ask, could
everyone just be quiet please.
Can I ask you to notice
how your mind is defaulting
in an involuntary
way, some of you,
back to work, back
to insecurities, back
to what it's all this
about, that they're not
in the present.
I mean you all can think
and do whatever you want.
But you'll get more from this
if you're silent and present
and not checking your
gadgets, just being here now
and paying everybody
else the compliment,
the incredible compliment
of being present with them.
Do you know that's what love is?
Love is just to be there.
Love isn't about rich,
parents, or partners,
buying expensive meals.
Love is simply about being
completely and utterly
present with somebody else.
There is nothing more that we
can ever be to anybody else
than to be totally,
unscatteredly
present in front of them.
That is love.
So have you all now got-- I
want you now to-- don't try this
yet.
I want you all please
to have the experience
of having your first ever--
What fruit are they, by the way?
Whatever they are.
You're going to have a
whatever they are orangey
kind of experience.
I want you to bring it to
your nose and just smell it.
And close your eyes
before you smell it
and then inhale, and put
the total concentration
into that smelling.
And let that orangey
smell percolate
and have it your whole being.
And I now what you put it down.
Very open your lips and
very, very slowly place it
on the tongue.
And just feel that sensation.
Feel the weight of
it on the tongue.
And totally mindfully,
just start chewing on it.
And just love, total
immersion in the experience
of that orange.
Total silence.
Just close the
eyes for a second.
And just notice the mind
goes and it comes back.
OK.
Let me just conclude.
This was a-- I don't normally
write about happiness
by the way.
I normally write books
about prime ministers
so that's what-- So my
new book is about Cameron.
It's out next month.
It's the inside book of Cameron.
I did a book on Blair, two books
on Blair and Brown, before,
but this is just a subject
that's really important to me.
So with Lord Layard we set
up action for happiness.
And in this book, I'm talking
about how who we are-- we
will be much like
our parents, and they
will be much like their parents
and your grandparents will
be much like your
great grandparents.
We carry on in these lines and
grooves of habitual behavior
unless we decide we want
to let go and discover
extraordinary depths.
And by extraordinary, I
mean precisely that word,
because it is extraordinary.
Most of us live
just ordinary lives.
I mean, we might
be rich and famous.
And I spend a lot
of my time writing
about the rich and famous.
Boy, are they often
very unhappy and they
lead very ordinary
life, skimming
on the surface of ambition
and fear of other people
and what other people might do
to them and suspicion and anger
and regret.
We can dive deep, deep,
deep down into life
and to lead to
extraordinary lives.
And to do that we didn't
have to acquire anything.
We simply have to let go.
We have to learn how to let
go of the anger, the fear,
the sadness, the depression.
And we have to start
experiencing in us
the real depths.
And to do that, recall the still
moments, the sacred spaces,
and getting in touch with our
bodies and with our feelings
is fundamental.
And I know you all know that,
but sometimes it's helpful,
particularly in an office, given
that you work alongside or not
too far from each other,
to recognize that together.
And in this book here,
I talk about pleasure
and what was the name of
that lord, by the way?
I'm not trying to laugh at
him, I'm feeling sad for him.
What?
Sewell.
I mean, he was trying
to find pleasure.
I mean, of course what he
was trying to do, I guess,
was to find something
that would make him,
deep down-- the
craving for happiness
is there in all of us.
And he looked for it
in the wrong place.
And it's very sad and I
certainly don't laugh at him.
But I talk about going through
pleasure into happiness.
And I talk about how we
could move towards happiness
by learning to, A.
accept ourselves,
B, belonging is
really important,
C, character, which is all
about playing to our character
strengths and not
being-- playing
from our great qualities and
not worrying too much about we
can't do.
About having a
discipline, which is
what I was saying there about--
otherwise it will just simply--
your life will suddenly go.
Empathy, really truly
emphasizing with each other
and with ourselves.
Having a focus in life.
Giving.
Undoubtedly those people who, if
you want to feel good, do good.
Do good to others.
It always makes us feel better.
Those of you volunteer will
know exactly what I mean.
And H is to health, and
taking our physical,
mental, and psychological
health seriously
is fundamental in happiness.
A happy mind does
equal-- and a happy body
will mean a happy mind.
If you jog and run
and you all know that.
And if you eat well, conversely
if you do the wrong things,
you won't feel happy.
And then five ways to get
beyond happiness, inquiry, being
on a journey, karma,
which is about thinking
about the hurt
you've done to others
and trying to seek
forgiveness, to forgive others
and on it goes.
So that's the book.
I don't know if there
are any questions in just
the remaining time.
It's a topic I absolutely love.
And it came out of my own
experience and to some extent
my family's experience
of being not very happy,
certainly my experience.
I was pretty profoundly
unhappy when I was younger.
So and it was near here.
It was about two
blocks south of here
that one day when I was
writing my doctoral thesis.
When I was at LSE, I used to
work at the British Museum.
And I went past this
secondhand bookshop
and there was this book that
said, do you want to be happy?
And I was kind of interested,
but didn't go and buy it.
The next day I
thought I would buy it
and it wasn't in the shop.
Because it was a
secondhand bookshop
they've got no idea who wrote
the book or what it was.
So as I say in the book,
I've written the kind of book
I would have wanted
that to be, so I could
have read that when I was 25.
OK any questions on anything?
Yeah.
We have about five or 10
minutes for questions.
OK.
No, I can see that.
Let me see if I can
explain what I mean.
The experience, my
experience in life,
is that there is a
radiant, inner stillness
and happiness within me.
And it's not anything
that I and the people who
I admire who write
and think about this
also happen to believe.
They believe that it's
not anything external.
It's not anything that
we have to acquire.
It is a case of letting
go to acquire it.
But to do that we
need to have a focus.
That was the point about focus.
So many people in life
don't have a focus.
They're not this way and
they're not that way.
And they get this promotion.
but then they think, is
this really what I want?
They go from that promotion.
My experience of being in
schools and a teacher and still
more ahead for the
last 20 years where
I come across many parents
is that many have just
been swept along into jobs
without thinking whether that
was really what they want.
So one of things I've
tried to do at schools
as well as giving them a really
big grounding in what we've
been talking about in stillness,
and positive psychology,
is to help them to find out
what they really want to do,
young people what do you
want to do in your life?
What do you love about life?
And if you want to
be a carer in life
and your parents want you
to be a bond trader, well,
sorry if they were
great parents,
they'd want you to be
what you want to be.
And that's why many parents get
it wrong, because for the best
reason in the world, they
impose their own thoughts.
So focus is about trying to
find out what your focus is
and getting in touch with that.
I think the other example
there would also be you
can see how they too can
be things that we let go of
and all this.
I first became really
interested in this
when I came across somebody
who-- has anyone come
across Martin Seligman here?
Very simple, Martin Seligman--
one or two of you have.
Martin Seligman spent his life
studying depression in America.
Very well known
and very celebrated
and one of the things he
learned about depression
was that people have a sense
of learned helplessness.
They learn to be helpless.
They learn to think that they
can't have personal affect,
that they can't ever get over
their neuroses or psychoses,
that they'll be
depressed forever.
It's a learned action.
But he then realized
that you can actually
learn optimism also.
And when he was elected
President the American
Psychological
Association in 1998,
he made his inaugural
address about why
is academic psychology,
not just American
and Britain and
Europe, the world
over, obsessed by the
abnormal, obsessed
by OCD and depression and
neuroses and addictions
and anxieties and fears.
Where are the studies
looking at the ingredients
of good organizations?
So Google is a
great organization.
And the way the
spaces are organized
shows how you could
be very imaginative.
What are the ingredients
of a great relationship?
So if you have a problem
with your partner, you can go
and you could talk
to a counselor.
And the traditional
way of doing it
is to say, well,
what's going wrong?
But this way says,
what's going right?
You know what is going
right in your relationship?
When are you having a
really good time together?
Are you having enough sex?
Are you going out to
the cinema enough?
Are you having enough fun?
Are you doing the kind
of things you used to do,
that you used to really enjoy
them as sacred between you?
Are you going out
on enough dates?
By the way, the
recommendation is
that you have two dates with
your partner every week.
And these are serious things
that we can take responsibility
for to make our own lives
happier, recognizing our lives,
being happy will make other
people's lives happier
around us.
So positive psychology as
opposed to traditional,
negative.
So much of academic
disciplines are actually
quite negative in the
way they look at life.
So that was the kind of genesis
to me of a lot of this work.
And Seligman's a key figure
in action to happiness,
or his influence is.
Time for one or two more
questions if there are any.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SIR ANTHONY SELDON:
There's a question there
saying, in a practical sense
how do you remind yourself
about the importance
of being present?
It simply grows.
And having people around
you who are also working
in that direction helps.
In the same way that having
people around you who are very,
very sort of like
that and agitated,
can make us feel
uncomfortable, you know,
people in the office,
people in our groups,
who are very insecure
can make us insecure.
Also people you go
at holiday with who
are very kind of angsty.
Flipping that round
the other way,
being with people who are
reflective and thoughtful and
present, looking in the eye,
just give us little reminders,
helps this to grow.
So it's a good thing
to be in mindful spaces
around mindful people.
Because, even though
is T.S. Eliot says,
Four Quartets, you
may all know it,
that the endpoint
of the journey--
can someone finish
that off for me?
Is to come back to the-- and
the end of all our travel
is to come back to the
place from which we left
and to know that place
for the first time.
He's just saying that
the end of all our travel
is to come back to
that same place.
But to know it, and that
place is our inner selves.
It's our inner depth.
So it's a very long
journey but actually
it's a journey-- it feels,
wow, it's a long time.
It takes a lot of
effort to do it,
but we're just coming
back to ourselves.
T.s.
Eliot, Four Quartets.
Last question.
I'll take both of them together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SIR ANTHONY SELDON:
Do I think-- why
has the Western world adopted
mindfulness in the last two
years and will it stay?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SIR ANTHONY SELDON: So let
me take that question first.
I think technology is
a neutral positive,
I simply don't--
Wellington, in my school,
the kids have these with
them, whatever they've got all
the time.
We don't ban them from lessons.
They are a fantastic enhancement
to learning to sense of wonder.
I mean it's just
unbelievably exciting.
Great teaching is helping people
discover things for themselves.
So some of you
would love history.
Some find it boring.
But what great history teachers,
they didn't tell you the story.
They said that the
battle of so on.
The French were here.
The Germans were there.
The British were there.
How would you have fought that.
You can use your gadgets to try
and work all that out and find
out who was on either side.
Where they're placed and how
you'd have fought the battle.
In terms of active learning, I
mean I just think it wonderful.
But obviously as
you all know, you
have to be the master
of your technology
rather than let the
technology master you.
So it's a neutral positive and
a wonderful positive too So
that's where I stand
in terms of that.
And just finally,
do I think it will
fade in the next few years?
Well, it might fade.
But it doesn't mean
that it will go away
because all that we're
being asked to do
is to get back in touch with
the simple and the natural.
I mean loving somebody,
caring for somebody,
having the experiences
your sacred spaces,
your special moments with
people, your stillest moments
in your life, your
happiest moments,
are moments of
complete simplicity.
Mindfulness declutters
us, descatters us
into coming into
the present moment,
so that we know that we're
there because we are there.
So just to finish, my last
words will be again T.S. Eliot.
He talked about all of this.
He talked about the journey
in life properly followed
and this would be the
meditation, mindfulness,
well-being movement.
It's about a condition
of complete simplicity
costing not less
than everything.
Condition of complete
simplicity costing not less
than everything.
And the everything
that it's costing us
is the letting go all the
other stuff so we can just
come together as human
beings and with ourselves
in complete harmony
within ourselves
and with other people.
It's been really
nice to be here.
Thank you so much
for inviting me.
[APPLAUSE]